[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour
le constat suivant je m'ennuie pas si
vous êtes dans ce cas m en tout cas moi
je m'ennuie le cowboy d'accélérer un peu
l'échéance fait beaucoup de vidéo sur
des smartphones des tonnes des tonnes de
smartphones et puis beaucoup de tournage
en studio parce que plus de déplacements
professionnels ce qui fait que c'est
toujours le même décor toujours la même
chose qui se passe je taise et
smartphones gps des smartphones et tous
ses smartphones se ressemblent alors pas
tous et notamment des différences la
corée nouveauté c'est intéressant ça
donne des bouffées d'oxygène mais
beaucoup en tout cas sur cent l'ont donc
stade nungesser beaucoup de tri y en a
certains que je testerai plus certain
que je testerai on va l'avoir déjà ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est je teste les
marques que j'aime et celle que j'aime
moins bon là je regarde pas ça
m'intéresse il ya bien une bouffée
d'oxygène l'année dernière lorsque j'ai
fait le trip avec amazon je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez rester l'émission ça
va cartonner on est aujourd'hui à
marseille on est ici ces appareils nous
sommes aujourd'hui à toulouse on est
aujourd'hui si elle est je viens tout
juste d'arriver à bordeaux et à lyon et
à strasbourg rennes montpellier nantes
unissent vous êtes prêts san acteurs
tony tomassi telliano mois de septembre
jusqu'au mois de décembre les travaux à
paris en ce moment ça m'a apporté une
vraie bouffée d'oxygène parce qu'en fait
ce qui était vachement cool là c'était
une nouvelle expérience partir avec une
équipe tournée c'était vraiment vraiment
vraiment autre chose arrêté ibrahim prat
il fera il sera intéressant et très très
formateur mais dans l'absolu constat
c'est que voilà je m'ennuie les
chaussées pas sur la même manière d'où
l'idée de venir changer
qu'est ce qui va changer première chose
toute la charte graphique ça fait des
mois que je bosse sur une nouvelle
charte graphique enfin pas moi moi et
une équipe derrière on bosse sur une
nouvelle sur graphique nouvelles
couleurs beaucoup plus dynamique
nouvelle ambiance et un nouveau logo
et regardez j'ai même la borne d'arcade
monsieur greu pas malin et si vous
regardez sur les flancs et bien vous
avez toute la nouvelle charte graphique
qui est posée là sa j'adore alors ça
peut faire un peu mégalo mais je vous
assure que l'idée c'est pas du tout
d'être mégalo mais c'est vraiment
d'avoir des objets qui représente
l'univers ici dans le studio avec des
petits boutons de couleurs vous avez
pareil sur l'autre côté tout la charte
graphique qui est posée franchement
j'adore je suis très très fan de cette
bande est en plus regardez bien l'ouvrir
et si vous voulez pouvait faire bar aria
du rangement pour l'instant c'est pas
encore bien organisée mais bientôt ça va
s'organiser et c'est une bande qui est
signée flex arcade il m'avait déjà fait
une borne avec mon ancien champ
graphique flex arcade souvenez vous
c'est un bartok c'était plus petits
c'est quand même un psy ou la vache la
lumière j'adore d'elle ok je tombe sur
un dell enfin c'est un écran
d'ordinateur la base c'est le seul moyen
d'avoir des écrans qu'à tiers en fait ok
je fais plus les katia way comics arcade
génial et c'est quoi ce bouton c'est le
volume à si le volume ok ça les haut
parleurs ici un combat y est je suis
fini weeds est oui mais la savak
d'heures travaillées préfecture de faire
le tour du jab moi je suis passionné de
teck donc mon but c'est quoi et bien
c'est de partager avec vous mes
aventures vous emmener découvrir de
nouveaux produits toutes les nouveautés
qu'on va pouvoir voir à droite à gauche
que ce soit du smartphone de la monde
connecté de l'ordinateur tout ce que
vous voulez tout ce qui vous fera
plaisir je suis un peu comme votre pote
qui vous prend par la main qui vous dit
tiens je viens moi regarde j'ai un
nouveau truc pour toi je te le montrer
or c'est super cool on est là pour
partager on est là pour découvrir on est
là pour s'amuser d'ailleurs si ça vous
botte ça vous intéresse une fois de plus
va vite à venir vous abonner que vous
actionnez la cloche comme ça vous serez
informés des cas une nouveauté qui
arrivera donc là on a continué bien
évidemment à parler tech mais par contre
on va le faire différemment
[Musique]
nous
[Rires]
où
et surtout j'ai un tout nouveau studio
nouveau studio qui a différence
d'univers ici c'est le coin salon le
coin on va venir tester les télés
pourquoi une nouvelle télé qui va le
tester à garder elle va venir se poser
juste ici c'est aussi le coin un peu
cocooning avec le canapé ce que j'adore
dans le nouveau studio c'est l'ambiance
loft vous avez de la brique ici
l'escalier qui va les tâches par là tout
est ouvert on a aussi un mur de pierre
il ya aussi une petite cheminée sur le
côté là c'est l'espace bureau pour
l'instant c'est pas du tout définitif ça
ça va changer ça permet de venir
travailler site c'est là où je vais vous
faire pour l'instant les live tweet mais
le studio va être complètement remanié
parce que derrière la bâche d'un placard
qui va partir et où je vais installer un
grand bureau avec tout mon matos pour me
refaire les lèvres twitch le montage et
compagnie à des jeunes entre ça va être
ici pour l'instant c'est un rangement
grand placard c'est très pratique mais
moi j'ai pas besoin de ça pas besoin de
tous ses placards l'a donc tout ça ça va
dégager je vais donc de mettre un grand
plateau avec un grand bureau et double
moniteur c'est ce que vous avez au fond
en fait on va venir les retrouver ici et
ça qui me sert à faire les plans du
dessus alors ça ça vient de chez
manfrotto si vous en voulez un cd mois
d'attentes j'ai commandé il ya quatre
mois ou tech 3 mois pour le recevoir
aujourd'hui ça c'est génial parce qu'en
fait vous avez un système de crémaillère
vous permet de le monter et de descendre
extrêmement facilement vous arrivez la
suite vous repartez si surtout hyper
solide on peut mettre n'importe quel
boîtier c'est très très bien moi j'en à
7 et 3 km sud qui va vraiment bien donc
ça on va le retrouver au fond on aura
donc pas de bureau là parce qu'il est un
peu petit on aura un grand plateau
double moniteurs qui vont arriver là je
vais aussi installé des éclairages à
demeure des éclairages leur faut que je
voie comment je vais faire ça mais je
vais mettre des panneaux led un support
pour la caméra de façon à ce que je
ferai les lives twitch également est ici
parce que vous verrez dans le dos et
bien c'est le mur de briques avec les
éclairages qui viennent du haut qui sont
vachement sympa il ya un autre truc que
je vais faire qu il pas encore fait pour
l'instant c'est qu'ici la dans cet
élément central ici eh bien je vais
installer un logo en gros alors je sais
pas si ça va être un lion je sais pas
exactement quoi ça c'est mon nouvel
outil travail situé en plein centre de
paris on est vachement bien à regarder
et en fait ce que vous voyez passer ici
là vous savez j'ai les moniteurs et bien
je veux venir violé tous bureau se faire
un grand îlot central ici sur le cas je
vais me reposer mon matos de podcasts
donc lorsque je vais recevoir des
invités pour du podcast mais pourront
venir ici on va pouvoir venir
enregistrer on pourra se faire aussi
plein de choses différentes plantes un
bref y'a plein de choses installé
peut-être un fond vert un fond bleu j'en
sais il ya plein de choses à faire pour
l'instant pas studio tour je vous montre
juste il n'est pas du tout fini encore
beaucoup de travail sur la configuration
sur l'éclairage sur le lieu mais je
voulais partager avec vous parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau début
c'est un nouveau départ il ya un nouveau
départ avec un nouveau lieu et ça c'est
très très cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
youtube reste mon canal principal donc
vous pouvez me suivre je mets tout
m'étais-je toutes mes vidéos là dessus
et j'ai publié plus en plus à d'autres
réseaux ce soit tik tok instagram
beaucoup de vidéos sur les risques
notamment va y avoir également du
facebook je prédis lorsque vous êtes sur
facebook c'était encore du monde sur
facebook je sais pas twitter et puis
bien évidemment sur twizz et on se
retrouvera sinon toutes les semaines pas
demain soir mais sinon tous les jeudis
soirs on se retrouvera à 21h en live sur
twitter pour parler de la tec de
l'actuelle de la revue tech et puis en
même temps regarder j'en profite parce
que là je suis à paris et je vous ferai
visiter quelques petits coins alors je
me réserve le droit de ne pas parler que
de teck je me réserve des fois le droit
de parler d' un peu autre chose ce sera
des sujets un peu à part mais la chaîne
reste une chaîne de teck ce qui ne
change pas ce sont les vidéos sur
youtube rien à voir avec le mouvement
derrière c'est juste en sorte qu'ils
soient pas les vidéos vont rester avec
les tests l'actualité les guides d'achat
les conseils tout ça ça ça reste ça ne
change absolument pas ce qui ne change
pas aussi c'est le podcast fréquence
grenat deuxième saison qui va arriver
très prochainement donc je vous mets
tous les liens dans l'indiscret sur ma
pouvez y aller vous abonner également
suivre le podcast c'est très cool
podcasts et sur youtube et sur toutes
les bonnes plateformes soit 10 heures
apple podcast le podcast spotify et
compagnie ce qui est cool avec le
podcast c'est que c'est un format qui
est vraiment différent on peut prendre
le temps peu plus le temps de discuter
de parler n'y a pas de limite pas de
contraintes de temps ça peut durer 10
minutes ça peut durer un quart d'heure
ça peut durer 20 minutes une heure une
demi heure bref peu importe le podcast
en tout cas super intéressant et qui
revient extrêmement rapidement avec un
tout petit décalage tout petit décalage
pas très très longtemps que finalisé de
calais tous les invités mais en tout cas
ça va revenir aussi très prochainement
et puis ce qui ne change pas c'est la
bonne humeur on est là pour découvrir on
est là pour se faire plaisir on est là
pour voir de nouveaux produits des
produits intéressants des fois des
produits pas intéressant je parle assez
peu de produit par intéressant on va me
dire deux fois que suis pas assez
critique parce qu'en fait je sélectionne
les produits dont j'ai envie de parler
je prends des produits qui me plaisent
des marques que j'aime bien vous avez
des foyers privés qui sont vraiment au
top du top qui sont un petit peu en
dessous du genre si tu toujours par
rapport aux tarifs c'est bien évidemment
si vous avez un produit qui coûte 200
euros va pas tant de la même chose s'est
produite
bien évidemment si vous avez un produit
qui coûte 200 euros va pas attendre la
même chose dans produit qui coûte 100
euros 150 taureaux bref donc j'ai
toujours restituer c'est vrai que des
fois j'ai vu en commentaire des trop
consensuelle tu vas pas à ses critiques
et tu vas pas être méchant je suis pas
là pour être méchant une fois de plus je
ne prends que des produits que j'aime
c'est la raison pour laquelle bien
souvent gens dit du bien parce que je
les aime bien ils me plaisent
s'il me plaisent pas je les prend pas
garde pas les bons prix que je rêve
d'aller produits qui ne plaisent pas un
aller simple est arrivé à force donc on
se retrouve dès demain pour continuer
bien évidemment à part les textes l'ateq
arrive d'une nouvelle manière de
nouvelles façons alors que des fois il y
aura des vidéos en studio qui bougeront
un petit peu moins mais l'idée globale
voyez c'est de se réinventer c'est de se
faire plaisir c'est de prendre du
plaisir c'est le partage un nouvel élan
nouvelle dynamique et j'espère que ça
vous plaira à demain ciao
[Musique]